In November,
1884 the New York Times ran a pretty interesting story and astronomer,
known only by the name,
aren't claimed to have discovered a cubic planet just beyond the orbit of
Neptune.
Less than 100 years later.
Another discovery was made this time by a man who not only named the planet,
but who also had maps and sketches of it's alien lifeforms,
coincidence,
crazy,
or are cubic planets possible?
Could humans live on a cubic world?
How would our climate change?
How would gravity be effected?
Could we stand it?
This is what f and here's what would happen if the earth was a cube,
all planets around,
but have you ever wondered why?
Let's go back in time,
say four and a half billion years ago,
a big cloud of gas and dust called a nebula collapsed to form a hot star,
which through its gravitational pull attracted all nearby matter and formed a
large rotating disk around its center.
After more than just a few collisions,
the matter orbiting the young son eventually grew into massive bodies with
strong gravitational centers.
They formed planets inside any given planet,
gravity pulls equally from all sides towards its center.
This accounts for their spiritual shape.
So because the earth we live on is a sphere and its gravitational pull is the
same wherever you go.
It means that as long as you're on a flat surface,
you'll be standing straight and tall.
But what do you think happens when you skewed the distribution of gravity?
So you want to live life on the edge,
then pick a side.
The earth has six faces now,
but sadly none of them or any fun.
That's because anywhere you go is going to feel like you're climbing up a steep
hill on the cube earth.
Gravity is strongest at the center of each of its faces.
So the further you are away from the center,
the more you'll feel it's Paul.
Hope you didn't take standing tall for granted.
The landscape along the earth's edges would be rocky and barren since all the
water would be pooled at the center of each face and the atmosphere of quality
along the earth's edges and corners would be too fin to support life or
nonexistent.
We'll come back to that later.
The new climate would depend on how the earth rotates.
If r cubed planet rotated on an access through two of its faces than the climate
would be kind of how it is right now on earth,
only more extreme.
The top and bottom phases would be polar while the remaining four sides would
enjoy an equatorial climate.
However,
if the earth was a cube that rotated through its corners,
then each side would have a temperate climate.
You could say goodbye to extreme temperatures and precipitation.
Sadly,
that means saying goodbye to your equatorial fantasy world too.
On the plus side,
you might just be able to walk into outerspace.
Since our atmosphere has held down by gravity and since gravity is now pulling
from the center of each of Earth's faces,
it means that the atmosphere would be thicker,
where gravity is strongest and thinner towards the edges.
What's more,
if the cubic earth had the same volume as are rounded world today,
then it's sharp.
Steep corners would actually poke out beyond our atmosphere.
These areas would be unprotected and therefore uninhabitable.
But who says he couldn't rent a space suit and stand on top of the world and
outside of it at the same time?
Would you do it?
What else could you do on a cubic planet?
Could you adapt?
What would we call ourselves on this six sided earth?
Cubists Cubans will never find out,
and that's probably for the best,
but we'll keep trying things out as long as you're curious new episodes of what
if,
or coming soon.
So be there or be square.